well I guess let me get started so I'm
Raj I work here as manager of quality
assurance here at Altru
so before I get started with with unit
testing and how it has been incorporated
into Mathematica I hope that I keep the
presentation small concise because I
know everybody here had has had lunches
and I don't want you falling asleep you
know so and if you have any questions
I'll try to keep it to the end so that
you know I'll have all the questions at
the end so going for going into unit
testing I mean I guess the question of
whether we have to do testing or not is
almost self-explanatory right because I
mean everybody here who has ever
developed software would know that as
John put it in the in the meeting today
if you have written code which is more
than five lines of code you know there
there is every possibility of a bug
coming up and especially if you have
software that you are develop developing
over time you want to make sure that it
works with the initial cases that that
you are developed it for so let me make
a small mention about the previous
effort for people here who have used
workbench you know I mean long uses of
of Mathematica and then Wolfram language
might have used testing in one sense but
there was no integrated way to convert
test from Mathematica to you know plain
text files testing notebooks or whatever
which you can use directly so one of the
long-standing features that that we
didn't have was you know built-in
testing into Mathematica and with this
we have taken the first step towards
correcting it I'll start off with a
notebook interface because I want to
show you how you know we'll start with
like a regular notebook which I'm sure
everybody here is familiar with and how
starting from here I can you know write
my functions and from there
I can convert them into tests run them
you know check them etcetera etcetera
play around with them and then finally
save them for later use you know so that
we can quickly run the test whenever we
want on-demand beat in Mathematica beat
n on a workbench or cloud so let me just
start off with a simple function let's
say I have I'm defining a function I'll
try to keep it pretty simple and now I
want to have another definition where an
for if it's a string I wanted to do
string lend or x squared now I mean
let's assume that this is my function
and you know my quick pass would be my
function of 1 you know whether it works
and then a few other tasks this is too
big I should probably make it a little
smaller
right of asdf and then my function of
right so when most people developing I
mean everybody's familiar with the
notebook interface so you know when you
usually write your whatever function I
mean this can be super complicated or
you know you can call a package to load
your functions then but usually you have
some use cases you know this is what
it's supposed to do
etc etcetera etcetera and when you're
writing it you you test it around this
way you can create sections you know all
the rich functionality that is already
there in the notebook interface
you know subsections and then you know
you can creep keep having my better
function let's say this takes two
arguments and there's something pretty
simple right
and I can have a few
that's for that you know I mean I can
you can make this notebook as long as
you want you can have as many cases as
you want now from here if there's a way
to convert to quickly convert this
notebook into a desk you know that
that's going to be awesome right I mean
everybody gets to this step but then
till now you would have to manually do
some copy paste stuff or write your own
parser or whatever to convert this into
you know as if you have used workbench
before so now we provide a toolbar call
as a testing tool bar it's found in the
Windows menu so if you click on the
testing toolbar you'll notice that if
you can see it here there is like this
little button at the top clicking on
that will automatically convert it will
keep all the Styles all the text I mean
all the notebook interface functionality
that's already there and convert it into
a testing notebook I'll make this a
little bigger so that people in the back
can see right so now you can notice that
there is little text here I mean this
will obviously be more visible on your
own machines and this reads input and
this reads expected output now most of
the tests have arranged have been
arranged in you know this is my input
this is what I expect it to return and
then you can have expected messages too
saying that you know this my input is
supposed to generate messages for
whatever reason to quickly add tests you
can either just type in you know one by
zero it will automatically create a test
you could click the new button here and
add test that way you know I'm gonna
purposely leave them blank you know I'm
not giving them any unexpected outputs
because I want them to fail clicking on
the Run button at the top will run all
the tests in the notebook in in the
order so it's just like you're a regular
notebook where in all your definitions
at the top will will be carried through
in each of the tests now you can notice
here that you know there is these
success bars or what I call as test
result bars there is something called
details here
if you can see all the way at the back
you know it has test ID well obviously
it's none because I haven't yet
specified any test ID usually when you
write tests you want to uniquely
identify each test as you know this is
my test or whatever so that when you run
it later and it fails you can identify
which test it was that failed and if you
scoot down further you'll notice that I
mean these two tests failed obviously
because my expected output here was not
given I mean it was null if you don't
mention anything obviously it takes it
as a null I can quickly hit the replace
output and I can either rerun the test
by clicking the button here I can do a
shift enter in the input to quickly
rerun the test and or I might point out
one thing is there is this test result
bar this is dynamic so whenever you
don't test that will be and you read on
tasks that it will be dynamically
updated in the test summary bar I mean
that's my name for it it's not the
official name but and this helping thing
has like a little tooltip you can see
what test it was you can quickly go to
whatever test you want but now notice
that there is this actual messages I
mean this reads actual messages for
people who can see at the back so here
for example I have a test this is my
input this is what I was expecting it
matched you can see in the details that
unfortunately I can't make that bigger
you know my expected my actual and
expected output are the same but it's
generating a message and I can quickly
oops
click that one and rerun the test to see
you know to sweet pass you can have
several tests and you you might also
point out that this has been updated
here I can choose to go through all the
failures in the test I mean right now
there is just one failure in the test so
I can use the buttons up here to
navigate between failures because most
of the time when we write tests we are
interested in failures if you right so
now if you have any inputs for example
let's say
I insert new input I mean you can copy
this input from any regular I know 123
cubed so this this can be copied from
any other notebook or you can just
create an input cell here and I mean
this is just like any regular
Mathematica notebook but now I can
convert this this input and output into
a test I can do that by clicking the
cell bracket and going to the mode
button here and using this convert
selection to test that should convert it
to in to convert it into a test and as
soon as you run it notice here that we
have run a total of eight tests there
one bar here got added I'm not sure if
you could see that but anyway so it's a
it's a good notebook interface for for
quickly generating tests you could you
could do several other features like
assigned test IDs lot of times you might
want test I guess unique identifier for
each of your tests this this button will
this button will add test IDs to all of
your tests all tests in the notebook now
here we are adding a UUID for each one
of them but you can customize it for
people who are interested in customizing
it I can show them how but we haven't
yet officially documented how to change
it then you can save this as a dot
double olt file I'm a lot of times
people complain that you know I want my
test tests in a text format because I
want to save them somewhere
look at them with other editors you can
save it in a dot wlt format can I just
save it as double T here I already had
it so I'm just replacing it and then let
me also see if the notebook I'll be
using the notebook later when I use when
I show you some of the functionality and
finally you can add messages add options
well obviously this is we need to fix
that issue but I think it's only because
of
the slideshow mode and and the
magnification but anyway this looks much
nicer when you use it at maybe hundred
percent zoom you can quickly add memory
constraints or you know time constraints
I'll go or all of these options in a
moment so so that's the so that's the
notebook interface so with the notebook
interface in I mean what we can do is
start from a regular notebook convert it
into a testing notebook run test there
play around there and then convert it
into a dot wlt file as a text format for
example if you want to see how the dot
TT file formats you know it's I'm just
doing a file print on the on the file
that we just saved it sort of looks like
this I'll go or what each of that stuff
means I mean it's nicely formatted for
you the inputs the expected outputs the
test IDs now looking at the code
functionality which makes all of this
happen I mean a lot of people here might
just want to write that's you know
without using the notebook interface
because they might want to
programmatically access it and change it
etc etc and it's best done in a next
file right I mean you might have a big
text file you might be changing or let's
say your function was taking two
arguments and now it's taking an extra
argument and you want to
programmatically do some you know bring
bring all the data in and then do some
replace sort of stuff to quickly update
all of your tests you could do that in a
dot TT file but anyway looking at the
verification test so this is the basic
the code test which which runs which
runs all the tests so I mean this is
like one of the most simple tests that
you can think of you know like the hello
world sort of thing to test you know my
input is one plus one and it should
evaluate to two it produces one of this
nice typesetting boxes and you can see
that my expected output was to my actual
output was two it also tells you how
much time it took
the dust if you look at the input form
of it you'll notice that there are
several it's it's a test result object
with an association in it
each of these are what what is called as
properties I mean I can make it look a
little better like this so test index is
sort of like an internal index of the
order of tests that are run I mean
obviously test IDs the outcome whether
it was a successes it's a failure well
or it's a message failure what the
expected actual outputs we're what the
messages were and how much time was used
by the CPU or and the memory used for
that evaluation so going a little bit
more into detail about its options
properties what you can do with this it
has three argument formats one is like a
single argument format where it expects
it the input to evaluate to true so if
for example if you have one less than
zero then you know it will be a failure
you know right sometimes you might have
for example you might do an evaluation
which will generate messages and that's
as expected to account for messages you
can account it in the third argument so
this is the input the expected output
and the expected messages so without
this for example notice that it's it's a
differently colored icon and here you'll
you'll see that the expected expected
messages was null and yet you were
generating a message going into some of
the options so we only support four
options at the moment although I think
this technically supports about 23
options or twenty twenty are options but
we officially support only four I hope
to change that in in the future versions
but we are sort of very careful in
looking at what we want to introduce as
first-class citizens in Mathematica so
let's take a look at the same test so a
lot of times when we write the test we
don't want to use
same q so for example when when you do
this test what is being done is this
input is evaluated and it will do a same
to of of that and of my expected output
so that's that's exactly what is going
on internally although I mean you know
there is a little bit more stuff
happening in the background but
sometimes you might you might not want
to use same key I mean you might want to
use a different function because you
know for so for example let's say you
you have this input and I just want to
make sure that whatever this returns is
an integer so one way to do it is using
match queue so you know this is my input
my expected output and my option is
match queue you can have you know
different types of same tests a good
example is if you're dealing with data
which is you know numerical for example
there will be machine pression errors if
you're running something which you know
I don't know D solve nd solve and it
returns like this huge expression which
has lots of machine pression values in
it that those values will be different
depending on which platform you run
there will be like my new differences
one way to account for them is and you
know just do a chop between my expected
output and my actual output and then
check to see whether it's a zero
obviously you can come up with whatever
type of test that you want to compare
the outputs with and the way you could
do it is by using same test now a lot of
times when we run tests we want to also
make sure that they don't exceed a
specific memory you know especially
useful in catching memory leaks or you
know they don't exceed a specific amount
of time one way to specify that for
example here I have two evaluations
range of five I'm doing a byte count to
see how many bytes it takes to store
that expression in Mathematica now if I
have my memory constraint less than the
amount
notice here that 160 bytes are required
to store this
expression so not sure if people can
read it in the back but you know here it
will say that it's a failure because the
current evaluation has exceeded the
memory constraint however if you
increase the memory limit you I mean the
test will pass as expected this is often
useful if you if you are particular
about you know about the performance of
the functions that you're writing you
want to make sure that they don't take a
large amount of memory or our time now
test IDs this is often useful I mean
being in QA I use this almost every time
every every time I write a test I always
put a test ID because I want to somehow
identify that you know this is the name
of that test because when I when I look
at failures as soon as I see the test ID
I want it to tell me something about you
know this is this is what the test was
so you could use it as study for that
and then the time constraint now for
example take a look at this valuation
takes about 3 plus seconds
it's a simplify on a trigonometric
function now if I give it obviously time
constraint less than that it's gonna
fail and you have nice-looking failure
messages about time time exaggerated
time constraint being exceeded now take
a look at the properties its supports so
finally I have run the test now I want
to extract things out of it I want to
see how much time it took to run the
tests I want to see how much what the
expected output we're what the actual
outputs fair etc etcetera etcetera so
these are the properties that each test
result object supports I can you know
ask what's the test index what's the
test ID you know what's the amount of
messages you can view it for example
here here I'm taking this test was was
the one that I ran here this so this is
my test and now I'm
I'm applying each each property to that
test to see what it return oops okay so
we have looked at an individual test now
I have a bunch of tests and I want a
function which will run all the tests
and generate a report for me right I
mean most of the time what we are
interested in is after the test creation
phase we'll be using this to run all the
tests every time you know that support I
think you can use in cloud and and
Mathematica
but Wolfram in the workbench you can
just use the tools that you have already
been using I mean all of this is
supported in workbench and all the tests
that you have already written in
workbench should also be backward
compatible so for example test report
can take a list of verification tests
you know here notice that I mean this is
my hello world and then I have
purposefully not accounted for messages
it will give you a short summary of the
success rate the tests that we run and
why they fail there are four categories
of failures that we are sorry three
categories of failures that we look at
failed with wrong results you know where
in the my actual output and the expected
output just didn't match then failed
with messages wherein though my outputs
who output was the same it was giving
extra messages and then finally failed
with errors now errors is sort of like
our fallback case whenever for example
the test doesn't run you know you might
be missing a brace in your in your test
option or whatever and the test isn't
run at all then it will fail with an
error so this is the file that I had
just saved I mean remember when I was
going through the notebook interface
I saved the text file and I can run the
text file right away it will give me the
success rate the tests that were run
failures etc once I go to go through the
properties I can show you how to
interact with it to get whatever
relevant data that is desired and I can
also run it using the testing notebook
so remember we have two two ways to save
one is using the notebook interface do
you want to use that one or converting
into a plain text file I mean you know
depending on which school of thought you
you like if you take a look at the input
form of the test report object you'll
notice that it's a pretty huge thing
it's again an association of
associations actually and it has the it
has lots of I mean it has lots of
associate it has the test results it has
the total time taken to run the entire
all the tests together it has you know
summaries that I'll extract in a
movement but before I get to that I
guess I will quickly go the options the
support supports three options I mean
all of these options should be pretty
familiar because I just went over them
in the previous slide now only the test
ID is not supported because you know you
don't usually want to have some sort of
test ID at a test report level I mean
it's sort of like a you know for all the
tests but sometimes you might want to
have like all the tests so you have
written ten tests but now you want to
apply run the ten tests with the time
constraint or you want to run the ten
tests with that memory constraint or you
want to run the ten tests with a with a
built in you know built-in function to
match the actual and the expected output
so for example this is a test where n
for example you have a test which is
pretty simple and then you also have a
test which has some sort of numerical
imprecision in it I mean a built-in I
fully put in a little difference here
and then I can write up my chop function
to quickly you know say that I care
about twelve digits of precision after
twelve you know just just get rid of
them and then I can subtract them and
see if if the if this returns true so
this one will make sure that both of
them pass if I have one more test for
example and let's say I reduce the
precision where and I'm whoops where an
I purposefully introduced
depression I mean obviously it will fail
this test and you can see that one
filled with wrong results the memory
constraint and time constraint is pretty
similar you know this takes 900 bytes to
run notice that in my verification test
I'm not accounting for the memory
constraint so I'm a accounting for the
memory constraint when I'm actually
running the test using the test report
function so this memory constraint will
be applied to all tests which were run
by the test report now I can take a look
at the test results and see that you
know this indeed filled a failed with
with the memory constraint now notice
here that I might have a test with a
memory constraint specified gone so this
is your and this is the regular
quantities that is supported I mean this
is exactly like what you would expect
out of out of a Mathematica notebook
interface I mean any any quantity any
Wolfram Alpha stuff you can just plug it
in and everything should just work right
away right so I'll skip all the time
constraint again it's the same same
thing where then you have a lot I'm
running over time so I'll quickly go to
the conclusion so it has a lot of
properties you can query the properties
to to see how it behaves and because I
want to have questions from you guys let
me make a quick conclusion so this is a
first step towards integrating testing
into Mathematica so it's not perfect yet
but it does give us a seamless
transition from tests into a regular
notebook to a testing notebook and then
save it as dotted loyalty text files
which you can use anywhere so they can
be run beat on workbench beat on desktop
and beat on cloud products it also has
backward compatibility for tests that
you might have already written using M
unit and what we plan to do in future is
enhance different variety of tests for
example maybe add performance tests etc
etc that's still under consideration and
we want to support handling or special
forms at typesetting one of the
drawbacks right now is law the rich
functionality in in the notebook
interface is not necessarily supported